[TYPEWRITER]
Hi, I'm Kristin George.
And I head up product
at TuneIn.
We have 40 million monthly
active users from
all over the world.
And TuneIn brings you the world
of live radio to your
smartphone.
So we're here today to talk
about the Android product and
why we're so excited about our
fastest growing platform.
Over the last two years, we've
been working on increasing our
overall retention of our
Android product.
In our first version of our app,
we focused on UI elements
that we thought would
communicate to users how to
move from screen to screen, or
navigate between tabs, and use
a mini player.
So we had our own way
of doing this.
And it really was this big
bar across the screen.
And it said swipe here.
And we thought that this UI
element was going to be
extremely successful.
And what we found is people
just weren't seeing it.
So we moved over to a Google
UI element that really is
being used in places like
The Play Store.
And so at first, we didn't think
that this UI element was
as prominent.
And what we found was--
when we released it and tested
it on our listeners--
we found that it was actually
much more successful than the
feature that we had in place.
And as a result, people were
discovering a new great
content that they wanted
to listen to.
So it ended up moving our most
important engagement metric,
which is listening hours.
And then as a result, people
were finding really great
content that they wanted to
listen to on our platform.
And they were finding more
reasons to come back and
listen to TuneIn.
What we found was by
implementing fragments, Google
is helping us handle all these
different device sizes and
resolutions, so that we were
creating a really great user
experience on different
platforms.
And so I'm going to show off a
little bit about fragments.
If I come in here, you can see
that there are three different
fragments on the browsing
side of this screen.
So the first is here.
The second is here.
And then the third is as you
choose a particular genre of
music to consume.
There's another fragment
over here on the side.
And so you'll see this with
our little mini player.
And this fragment moves from the
side of the screen during
a tablet UI to the bottom of the
screen during a phone UI.
And what we did is we invested
once, and then Google is
helping us--
through this process--
conform to all the different
types of screen
sizes that they have.
We decided to make a very
content-first screen.
So a user can come in here and
they can say, these are all my
favorites as far as genres.
And then we can show them
the world of live
content as it happens.
So this is our very content-rich
experience that's
made for tablets.
I always shipping a new
app every two and a
half to three months.
So what that gives us the
ability to do is lean in to
the new features that Google
puts out into their releases.
So an example of this is
rich notifications.
And you'll see that we made it
really easy for people to
favorite stations and songs
that they like, stop, and
play, and then also discover
new content
with our Jump button.
So you'll see that we have a
full, rich notification, and
our users, as a result, feel
like we're constantly
improving our app, and making
them feel like we're paying
attention to them, and
that we're always
building new things.
So I'm looking forward
to continuing
to improve our product.
Always reaching for
higher retention.
And I really appreciate
your time.
So thanks for listening.